you gentlemen are from Great Britain
what's your take on this I think people
with trauma ties we did a show last
night in Thousand Oaks and they were
just desperate to laugh they were so
traumatized weren't they it's almost
like doing therapy making them laugh and
you know really I mean normally we could
enjoy this but we can't nobody in the
world can enjoy this no I think you're
right you know I was thinking some
people say look some people say what can
you what what are the things you can't
make jokes about yeah I think it's very
difficult to make jokes about it there's
some at the moment because there's a
sense of hopelessness right
I mean what do you do with the oldest
guy who's ever been elected president
who is clearly unqualified for the job
that's that's quite a thought you know
well so we can find a silver lining like
the merchandise the merchandise yeah
it's great merchandise and he's going to
have an interesting cabinet I was
watching CNN yesterday and he's gonna
have Christie's gonna have Giuliani it's
gonna have Newt Gingrich right he's
trying to get LJ Simpson
[Laughter]
I called you oj said no nation but the
point is he could start a pirate ship
with that
[Laughter]
I think we're gonna find out we're gonna
give we're gonna give him a chance
President Obama Hillary Clinton I've
said let's give them a chance the other
shot yeah I think that we're we're
asking we're asking your country and
other countries to give him a chance
just give him just give him a few more
hours yes and the nice thing is he's got
Putin to advise it because it uses the
old KGB I mean Putin after all you know
he's probably a very nice chattin kind
to his children all that kind of thing
but he was head of the KGB yes one of
the most fearsome intelligence units of
all time and the KGB had a very very
simple principle I know if you know this
it was accuse the opposition of exactly
what you're doing himself right and I
thought that that was what Trump was
doing yeah and as a result Putin has got
the president
[Applause]
you